if there is anyone out there
who still doubts that America is a place
where all things are possible
who still wonders
if the dream of our Founders is alive in
our time
there's still questions the power of our
democracy
tonight is your answer
yes that of course is Barack Obama in
2008 after becoming the first black
American elected president of these
United States and Pulitzer prize-winning
journalist and author Wesley Lowry
argues that that moment the moment you
just saw helped ignite a cycle yes of
racial progress but met by racial
backlash what he calls a white lash in
fact it's the title of his new book
American white lash a changing nation
and the cost of progress Lowry was a
correspondent for the Washington Post
and also for our own 60 Minutes Plus and
he joins us now Wesley thank you very
much for being here thanks so much for
having me congratulations on the book uh
I think you should begin by laying out
uh defining for us if you could what a
white lash is of course well you know in
our country our history is in a lot of
ways a tug of war between two
diametrically opposed forces forces of
white supremacy and I don't mean that
collically I mean the actual literal
idea of of a racial caste system and and
anti-racist forces people who have
fought for a more just Equitable Society
the abolitionists the civil rights
movement and so what we see in that tug
of war is that in moments of racial
advancement of racial progress
it's not inevitable they've now won the
grapple that the other side of the of
the Rope always tugs back and pulls back
and so when we think back to 2007-2008
right we see this Ascension of an
unlikely black man with a funny name to
the presidency of the United States of
America is comes at a time when
immigration is fundamentally changing
the demographics of our country and what
that meant was that for as many people
were as excited for this Victory there
were many people out there for whom this
stoked and anxiety a frustration a fear
and we've seen the pullback yeah you
called it you said uh white supremacist
force was being Unleashed that very
night and that research has come to show
that that while many people believe yes
there's some anti-black bias but there
are also people that believe that a lot
of white people felt that they had been
that they were discriminated against too
which I thought was a very interesting
premise that the polling showed that
Americans were divided by how much
progress the election of a black
president represented that actually
white Americans believed presented more
progress than black Americans did yes
and by the end of the Obama
Administration a majority of white
Americans believed they were racially
discriminated against why does this
matter because it starts to explain why
we have the success of a movement like
the movement that elects the former
president Donald Trump it helps explain
why politicians use things like the
appeal yesterday from Ron DeSantis to
ban Birthright citizenship for example
these plays to kind of a nativist
feeling of the country is changing
things are different a reactionary
movement that's very powerful but as I
lay out is not just about political
rhetoric that has real life consequences
for real people no Wesley you say some
leaders allow this fear to be weaponized
knowing that it can result in tragedy
and that we have to speak up and
acknowledge that this is happening that
what we see time and time again this era
is actual violence and that's violence
against Jewish people Muslims black
people immigrants and that that violence
we
think about it through our political
lens very often but we have to think
about it through that human lens that
when we demonize groups of people
whoever those people are immigrants
refugees black Americans talk about
crime about gender and sexuality that
people out there really do get scared
and that for those of us from those
minority groups it could cost us our
life you do write about the alienation
that white Americans feel that they feel
that they're being discriminated against
and at the same token they also will
point to people like Barack Obama or
even Senator Tim Scott a black
Republican and say I reject the notion
that this is a racist Society because
we've had a black president because we
have a black Republican running for the
presidency of course and what's
interesting is that there have always
been the the ability to try to use
whether it be individual cases or
individual folks to deflect these bigger
societal criticisms or people who will
say well I don't feel this experience I
don't feel particularly privileged I
don't feel particularly uh in a better
position than other people that what we
have to remember is that when we talk
about race and we talk about whiteness
we're not talking about biology right we
know there's no biological race we're
all humans around the table right that
we're talking about a social construct
and that whiteness in American sense is
not even just about skin color right but
it's about this idea and this concept of
who is truly American in this idea and
then when we see these political appeals
to let's go back to how things used to
be in the good old days
make America great again or America
first right that that appeals to
people's sense of this country changing
and it's shifting and it being different
and that perhaps they'll end up being
the losers of History so we break this
cycle how Wesley
well I think well if I really knew the
answer I wouldn't be here I would be out
making millions of dollars and fixing
Society right but I do think a huge part
of that is that you have some thoughts
yes I do have some thought you have some
thought the uh I think we have to be
willing to look things in the eye and
call them what they are right because
when we accept that this type of
political rhetoric has real life
consequences it demands of us to treat
it more responsibly to call out people
who do it not to play Silly games or
what is this an appeal to or we don't
know or how is it I think that so often
in the Trump years our institutions
needed to be bolder and clearer about
defending our journalistic institutions
they're talking about all of our
liberals there's so much more we could
say we've got to leave it there Wesley
Library thank you very much the book is
American white lash it is on sale right
now